i i'm sure you're aware of this about
like what's happening right now in
america and how popular uk drill is
becoming mm-hmm
are you familiar with this not too
familiar but yeah bro
bro
i'm not i'm not dude i'm serious there's
there's a song by central c do you know
central c mm-hmm you've heard of him
yeah do you know central city i have to
teach him about drilling
hey do you know this rapper in england
listen there's there's a genre of music
called the uk drill
and uh central c is a young bloke is
that what they're called
he's the mandem he's yeah he's one of
the man the bloke yeah yeah is bloke a
good word bloke's more like
a security guard like an english thing
you would say like a white english thing
no he's not well well what is what is uh
i think he's a guyanese yeah
whoa he's like a quarter indian and then
what's the other half i think irish so
he's don't quote me
a little bit half of his family's like
he's oak at least yeah you know half his
family's little yeah
[Music]
anyway
okay so he had this song and then the
the opening lyric was just so catchy
yeah how can i be homophobic yeah right
and then immediately you you're like i
would like to know how you could be that
way
and then he has a good
answer answer his [ __ ] is gay yeah yeah
yeah he keeps explaining it to him like
he doesn't know and that's but he keeps
looking at me like i'm i think he's
wondering i think he's like is this dumb
ass really gonna explain to me like i
don't listen
listen a lot has changed since you
started hip hop
you started hip-hop i know this had
hip-hop didn't start in the bronx it
started in east london yeah okay
with the nasty blokes
because originally like you know we can
go back we'll tell the man them about it
so
you know back before that before there's
grime there is
what was it there was garage or
something uk garage garage
and then before that what drama and base
or something we called it jungle back
there but that's
am i allowed to say that
yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
[Laughter]
you know sometimes things there's just
people in the neighborhood you know just
what is that it's the white people going
with people it was
okay so we have grime pops up at this
time
is nobody rapping here no people are
rapping and people are rapping but more
like
what you would consider rap like hip-hop
so grime represents the first version of
rap that is like authentically i don't
want to say to this dem that we're doing
that
but
it was in our own
voice yeah you know i mean from our like
our own perspective
you know dressing overdressed just it
was more it was more british yep you
know what i mean yep there was rappers
before but it was more like boom bap
kind of inspired by what was going on
then in the early 90s or whatever 100
and ours was like different bpm like
completely different way you would
you would perform
um
it was it was probably as inspired by
jamaican dancehall music as it was
american hip-hop yeah you know do a lot
of people know that that like rap is
a version of this jamaican dancehall
music like rap rep rap rap like even
early on yeah i think uh what who's like
cool like in that yeah yeah jamaican but
is that more known here
um i don't
probably not by a younger generation
right now okay okay no it's not really a
story that's told i feel like that's
kind of lost in in the states as well
yeah okay yeah i feel like people are
like curtis blows started rapping and
then that's where it began growing up in
texas i didn't ever hear that yeah
yeah so i don't know that's what i was
always understood that the influence
came from these like jamaican like dance
hall kind of djs who would rap slash dj
because when we done it we would like
you know run instrumentals and you would
like
you would constantly
like you would mix instrumentals like
one after the other like mix into each
other and everyone would just go back to
back and then you'll get a wheel up you
know what i mean but that was more like
how they would do it in dancehall music
you know i never really heard like in
the stuff we was listening to at the
time
like i don't know would be like the
nazis in the jay-z's and whatever
was very much like them just kind of
freestyling over
over a beat yeah you know i mean it
wasn't really
it wasn't really like i don't know maybe
maybe maybe i'm wrong but it wasn't
really um
like 10 guys going back to back on the
instrument or if you know what i mean
yeah
yeah they didn't have that too many
times yeah and like sometimes they would
have like a gang record where it's like
um
um this person's crew and this person's
crew come together and it's almost like
a competition of who really has the best
verse on the track ah
those are like far and few in between
when they would look like that yeah i
feel like they do that a lot more and
especially dancehall they do that a lot
where it's just a bunch of dudes yeah i
have like a rhythm yeah they have a
rhythm and everyone will go and vote
with that same reading yeah
like yeah i don't really see that in
like american here but i didn't see that
when i was you know coming up so that's
where we took influence from
that uh you know
right and what's the biggest difference
in your opinion that sets grime apart
from american hip-hop and even garage
in its early uh
from american hip-hop in its earliest
days was
the bpm like the tempo of it that's
another thing like everything was at 140
bpm everything had to be that speed
like now it's like different they caught
stuff ground but it's not really
technically growing but grime was 140
bpm
um and hip-hop was a lot slower
and from garage
the difference between grime and garage
was
garage was more like
and garage mcs because garage was more
like vocal garage
so it'll be like a b and then like
someone singing
and then you'll have this space where
there's like eight bars where the beat
would drop and you've got eight bars and
then it'll go back to seeing it so as an
mc you just had to deliver that eight
know what i mean and for the rest of the
time you're just hyping up the crowd and
you know you're more like a host
with a good eight bars and i'm super
like playing down but i'm not dissing
that and we was more like we are the
song yeah we're the song we're spitting
versus chorus with storytelling you know
what i mean and that was kind of
taken from american hip-hop now
there was a song that came out
i don't even think this is the real name
of the song
but pow yeah power is the name of the
song but and what's in the beginning
it's called forward rhythm yes why do
you know you googled that nope
so
my understanding of pow
is that like this was one of the first
songs to be like banned almost like
there was like signs saying djs don't
play this because they were like mosh
pits and [ __ ] yeah do you remember this
happening and do you remember feeling
like is that the first sense of like oh
there's a real authentic thing that's
kind of happening in this uk hip-hop
yeah i remember i don't remember feeling
oh this feels like something's happening
it was just quite annoying you know i
mean that we couldn't that you couldn't
even play everywhere we were playing was
getting shut down you know what i mean
why was it getting shut down because
police just didn't want it to happen
really you know i mean it's just
which was weird because there would be
like
[ __ ] rock concerts with white guys
motion but when it was like
2000 black guys moshing it was like oh
no no no that's a problem yeah you know
i mean
so it was annoying at the time
but yeah looking back it was like there
really was something happening but you
know when you're in something you don't
you don't know what's going on you're
not pretty you're just in it he's just
doing it that yeah we're going to the
pirate radio and just
we're building something but it's not
like we're building a company and we're
seeing results yeah i mean yeah yeah
yeah it's just this is just what you
know yeah
you should let white people have mosh
pits
now did you think that
do you think that people were attaching
as you look back
do you think that people are attaching
themselves that they felt like
represented them that there was like
their own
i'm not saying that this is like an m m
thing but like you know how like when
eminem came out i think there was a lot
of white people that outside of just
seeing like a white person they also
felt like someone talking about like the
angst this happened with nirvana as well
and like just touched on like a chord
that people are feeling 100
100
it was the first time
uh people had ownership over what they
was listening to yeah you know i mean
like they felt like it was their stories
being told yeah yeah and as much as we
love american hip-hop it's not your
stories it's not yeah so we're we're
we're listening to it like we're
watching
boys in the hood or something yeah and
learning about uh you know i mean like
here in nars and how he describes
queensbridge and you just [ __ ] think
[ __ ] you know it's almost like but
you're amazing instead of imagining it i
mean but when a guy is spitting and
talking about
around the corner and and that guy up
there and you know that guy is in that
shop that he goes to whatever and the
beef that's happening and he's talking
about it you're like [ __ ] no this is
like this is our [ __ ] yeah
oh [ __ ] yeah yeah i mean so it was like
yeah it was
yeah do you like the music now uk what's
going on now yeah
yeah yeah
like i like loads of it but it's not
it's not as
close as it was that like i said it had
to be 140 and that's a bit you know i
mean now it's kind of
you know um it can be whatever you know
whatever like guys
i mean there's still like
you know genres like you said uk drill
or there might be like afro
beats going on or i mean there might be
some guys still doing like traditional
grime
more hip-hop style but what i like is
i like
i like it to feel like a blend you know
i mean i
i like to make music that
gives you
the feeling of garage even though it
ain't a garage speed or whatever but it
just might be in something it might be
in the way i pitch up the vocal that
gives you that feeling of courage i like
my jamaican roots to come through you
know i mean i like the attack from
graham you know i mean so i just i like
that male important that's right
eclectic thing
yeah yeah yeah like like
you know and a lot of guys do in america
like sometimes i hear kanye i'm like you
you
you might hear um
wait till i get my money whatever in it
and it the street guys probably [ __ ]
with it even though he's not street but
he's right he's something about it
yeah essence but then he you know he you
got that
like kendrick he's my i think he's one
we're talking about andre he's one of
the best guys to ever wrap i think
kendrick's one of the best guys to to
ever wrap and he he's great in like
it doesn't feel like
he's a part of the street life but
he can observe it incredibly well and
then tell the stories about it yeah it
gives you that feeling like so so well
many different feelings either because
he grew up in it yeah yeah yeah he knows
it but when he wants to get jazz
influence as well like pimper butterfly
or whatever he he gives you i don't know
it's just it's beautiful you know what i
mean but i like the mesh that's what i
like mm-hmm
yeah
yeah i'm curious about like
who your counterpart is in america
like who do people say do they do they
say nas ever that's been said yeah yeah
how do you take that
i don't know it's tough because not he's
not he's not [ __ ] nars you know what
i mean he's like yeah but to to you i
mean to somebody you might be there
you know what i mean like because they
relate to what you're saying in the same
way that these kids growing up in
queensbridge or listening to naza's
stories and going holy [ __ ]
but i say that more because like
there's a real uh attachment to the
artistry you know and uh like at least
coming up in new york
i mean nas was just like yeah he was an
artist and when i say artist i mean like
he puts the art in front of the commerce
that's not to say he doesn't want to
make money like please believe
everybody's in this yeah the root of the
jay-z knives beef if you like knowledge
you just you really liked that you felt
like you put art i just yeah i loved him
i just loved him like experimenting like
there's that song that not a song rewind
and i was like what a cool thing to do
just like play with the genre like tell
the story backwards see what happens
right and it's like i don't know i was
listening to a lot of your stuff and i
was even listening to that interview
with the colin like it was actually
easier for me to understand it when you
guys were doing it without any music in
the background and like the
attention-like detail and
and just hearing you talk about it it's
a fine line
that i know i also feel like i have to
like walk which is
here's the way to make the most money
which is not necessarily going to make
me happy and here's the way to make the
[ __ ] art
that will make me happy and hopefully
make some money yeah yeah i'm with you
and and here's the way to make the art
that
would
has longevity or the art that will allow
me to be around in another 10 years
you know
like because you can
you know you can make that art that okay
this might work now flavor of the moment
but this might not help
um this might not age well right what's
the legacy you're leaving behind with
the music yeah exactly and i'll see you
both ways and some guys are like no they
want
they want to make the money now yeah and
and you know fair play to them yeah but
i've always entered this like
you know i want to be around in 10. yeah
and then when it's 10 i want to be
around in another 10. you know and how
old were you when you started rapping
and like coming up in that scene you
know like 16 or something oh really and
was it when he first started making
songs it was 15
16. was it what was it dangerous back in
the day like in that specific time or
where were all the guys really focused
on the art it was it was dangerous it
was dangerous it was dangerous from
garage because as as sweet as garage
sound that's what the gangsters used to
rave to
you know what i mean so there was a lot
of shootings in garage clubs
yeah when you hear garage now you're
like how the [ __ ] can you show me you
know yeah but that was quite dangerous
and um
and our and our raids when we started
them yeah occasionally there was there
was trouble or whatever but
it didn't feel as serious as the garage
thing but then
because
we were participating it was it was
always about the
the art for
for us anyway you know what i mean and
that excitement of
just um
just performing and getting the
opportunity to yeah do something you
love in front of people you know